all right Amanda is with us in Little
Rock hey Amanda your question for Rachel
and I hi Dave I'm so excited to get to
talk to y'all my question is this I have
three children one is a 19 year old in
college I have a 14 year old son and an
11 year old son how do you need program
your older kids from their sense of
entitlement that they somehow had gotten
and they are being a bad role model for
my youngest son give me an example of
when they would be entitled mom did a
child thinks that he should do nothing
at home in the way of chores and that
sort of thing but he also thinks that he
should get everything that he wants
Rachel what would have happened at our
house if that happened well for us
for instance the working thing wasn't an
option you know mom and dad they did a
twist on it where you get Commission
versus allowance so you get paid if you
do chores and that kind of concent
advise your child but when coming that
when it came to the end of the day I
mean you you had to work that was an
option and then we had to save up and
pay for things did they bless us every
now and then with some stuff absolutely
absolutely but we learned about saving
up and paying for things and so I guess
that's just how we grew up so
deprogramming them I think will be
difficult but I think if you put those
boundaries in place I was gonna guess 13
14 15 okay yeah yeah that's just trouble
and a human body at that age and so
there's exceptions but most of them are
just a little crazy because the hormones
are going crazy so the first thing I do
is I sit down say hey I'm your dad and
my job is to teach you to have skills so
you can win later in life and so you
will brush your teeth you will say yes
ma'am and yet and no ma'am and yes sir
and no sir you will keep your word and
you will work and you will get your
grades and you will go to class and you
will be in school when you're supposed
to be in school and if you don't
duct tapes gonna be involved you're
gonna have no freaking life I'll take
you to a chair and you'll be in there
the rest of your life now that's a
metaphor I wouldn't really do that but
but I don't mind threatening them with
all kinds of things so he's going to do
these things because they're good for
him and he needs to hear that before you
make him do them just because otherwise
it feels random to him that makes sense
okay in other words it's not optional
it's not being mean or are being you
know disciplinarian or anything it's
just you're going to learn to do life
skills you're gonna learn to drive a car
properly or you don't get to drive a car
you're going to work you're not gonna
leave the house and you're going to
learn to do these things and that you
know it's just not optional at some
point so you kind of break the back of
it with strength of parenting is one
thing to do and then teach them to count
their blessings as they go along the way
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you
you